am golf von neapel wo alles so süß
schmecken kann macht korvetten 19 das
leben dieser tage bitter corona nimmt
die luft zum atmen
die zweite welle trifft die küstenstadt
wie ein tsunami wut und verzweiflung
stadt deutsche liter wir erleben eine
stadt deren menschen tief getroffen sind
das stolze napoli verändert sein gesicht
kleine steine brechen aus dem mosaik im
traditionsreichen gambrinus gibt es an
diesem tag den vorerst letzten espresso
wegen des lok downs muss das gran café
schließen ein riss in der vertrauten
welt denn das 1860 eröffnete gambrinus
ist nicht irgendein kaffee es ist ein
emotionaler ankerpunkt eine institution
der tempel des neapolitanischen espresso
cafés mit berühmten gästen aus wild yam
preuß hatte selbst kaiserin sissi ein
eis doch nun weiß hier keiner wie es
nach der krise weitergeht
diese gesamte situation sie nimmt uns
die luft zum atmen aber so bedauerlich
es ist wir müssen damit umgehen
und wenn das der preis den wir zahlen
müssen dann sind wir dazu bereit
so wie wir in dieser stadt seit jeher
uns den problemen gestellt haben immer
in der hoffnung dass neapel und die
neapolitaner nicht vergessen werden
aber genau das befürchten sie jetzt
warme die aria sagt man in italien
hunger nach luft den hat ganz neapel in
der stadt am fuße des vesuv brodelt es
nicht nur in vulkanischem untergrund
ende oktober entlud sich der frust über
die erneuten tour ohne auflagen der
regionalregierung über die
einschränkungen für restaurants und die
kleinen geschäfte viele neapolitaner
fühlten sich ihre existenzgrundlage
beraubt
wer hilft uns wir sind jetzt schon
erledigt wir sind jetzt schon leben der
tote leute warum habt ihr uns den krieg
erklärt wegen kuwait ist alles
geschlossen habt ihr das denn kapiert
ihr habt uns dass klagen gemacht die
krawalle angefeuert auch von
gewaltbereiten hooligans des ssc neapel
der fußballclub ist für viele
neapolitaner zweite heimat die spieler
stars allgegenwärtig auch im geschäft
von krippenbauer gennaro die video auch
ihm fehlt die luft im stadion das für
die fans geschlossen ist aber für die
randale der tifosi seines klubs hat er
kein verständnis
ein teil unserer fangemeinde war an den
protesten beteiligt die abend ernährt
und statt aber zum glück ist es nur
einmal zu ausschreitungen mit diesen
gruppen und der polizei allen anderen
protesten haben die leute doch friedlich
für ihre rechte demonstriert gennaro
kann die wut verstehen die aus der not
erwächst schon vor dem lockdown machten
sie hier in den berühmten via san
gregorio ameno kaum geschäfte und dabei
wäre jetzt vor weihnachten hier dichtes
gedränge
so wie vor einem jahr als wir gennaro
schon einmal besuchten
und heute gähnende leere kein umsatz
seit sonntag 0 uhr gilt nun sogar der
locker und für ganz napoli anders als im
frühjahr hat die zweite welle auch den
süden voll erwischt kampagnen ist nach
der lombardei die am stärksten
betroffene region italiens das hospital
antonio carter rallye ist das größte
krankenhaus kampagnen ihr arbeitet dr
giuseppe wie sonne in der notaufnahme
schon vor krone haben wir ihn für einen
bericht begleitet schon damals war die
versorgungslage angespannt jetzt dürfen
wir ihnen nicht mehr drehen dr wie so ne
kommt nach dem dienst völlig übermüdet
vor die tür
was uns momentan fehlt sind platz für
die patienten und ausreichend
medizinisches personal
wir kommen leider insbesondere in dieser
region aus einer langen periode von
einsparungen für die kostendeckung gab
es pauschale kürzung
das bedeutet dass alles gekürzt wurde
ohne darauf zu achten ob es sinnvoll ist
die wahrheit ist dass dieses virus uns
endlich die augen geöffnet hat uns ein
dieser schock video aus dem katar rallye
hospitalisierte wenig später im internet
und bestätigt auf erschütternde weise
das was uns dr wie so ne geschildert hat
auch italiens regierung in rom zeigt
sich alarmiert wegen der zustände in
neapel und kann doch nicht verhindern
dass vor einer klinik kurve patienten
auf behandlung warten im privaten pkw
stunden lang und notdürftig beatmet mit
sauerstoff pharma die aria hunger nach
luft vor der notaufnahme ganz kampagnen
wird infolgedessen zur roten zone
erklärt die gesundheitliche notlage
trifft eine stadt in wirtschaftlicher
not von der die kamera profitiert durch
corona geht die schere zwischen arm und
reich noch weiter auf glanz und armut
sind neapolitanische geschwister
wir treffen pamela bruder am spanischen
viertel dem stadtzentrum
die 39 jährige arbeitet als lehrerin an
einer schule die sich skujat salate die
bambini nennt schule an der seite der
kinder
es reicht sich um zu schauen um zu sehen
wie viele menschen hier auf engstem raum
zusammenleben
die zahl der schulverweigerer und
abbrecher ist hoch viele mädchen
bekommen früher kinder und die
kriminalitätsrate ist ebenfalls hoch
wir bieten hilfe an um die situation
hier zu verbessern
sie zeigt uns ihr schulprojekt den
unterricht auf der straße noch vor dem
lockdown viele eltern ließen ihre kinder
schon vorher zu hause aus angst dass sie
draußen in die hände der camorra geraten
doch auch in den engen wohnungen sitzen
die kinder oft nur vor dem computer weiß
perla bruder
unsere kinder haben eltern die
gefängnisinsassen sind sie haben ein
elternhaus als umfeld das eher schwierig
ist deswegen ist die schule wie eine
rosafarbene insel eine glückliche insel
von schulschließung und online
unterricht hält sie gar nichts
pamela unterrichtet italienisch lesen
und schreiben aber sie vermittelt auf
der straße eigentlich noch viel mehr in
der pandemie ein bisschen luft zum atmen
diese kinder werden ihre hoffnungen
beraubt
sie sind die ersten die nicht daran
glauben eine würdige zukunft zu haben
deswegen ist es unsere aufgabe als
lehrkräfte ihnen eine vision eine
mögliche zukunft aufzuzeigen
ende november so heißt es jetzt sollen
die schulen wohl wieder öffnen denn die
kinder leiden besonders warme die aria
fahne die futuro sie alle haben hunger
nach zukunft am golf von neapel